Nastenka's History Half my story you know already,
that is, you know I have an old
grandmother.
If the other half is as brief as
that, I interrupted laughing, be quiet and listen.
First of all, you must promise not to
interrupt me, or else I might lose track
of what I'm saying and end up all
muddled, so listen quietly, will you?
I have an old grandmother.
She's been my guardian ever since I was
a little girl, because my father and mother
both passed away when I was very young.
Grandmother must have been better off financially in
the past, for she often recalls the good
old days.
She's fond of talking about how things were
when she was younger, about the elegance of
society, the way people behaved, and how different
everything is now.
She taught me French herself at first, then
hired a teacher for me when I got
a little older.
When I was fifteen, and now I'm seventeen,
so it wasn't so long ago, we stopped
the lessons altogether.
That was around the time when I began
getting into mischief.
I won't tell you exactly what I did,
because really it wasn't anything serious, but it
was enough to upset grandmother.
One morning she called me to her side
and said that because she was blind and
couldn't keep an eye on me, she had
to take drastic measures.
She took a pin, yes, a real pin,
and fastened my dress to hers.
Then she declared that we would sit like
that for the rest of our lives unless
I started behaving better.
Can you imagine?
Sitting there, tied to her, day after day?
At first there was no escaping her.
I had to work, read, and study right
beside her.
I wasn't even allowed to take a step
away without her permission.
I did try to outsmart her once.
I persuaded Fekla, our charwoman, to sit in
my place while grandmother was napping.
Fekla is deaf and doesn't hear much of
anything.
Grandmother was dozing in her armchair, so I
thought everything would be fine.
I slipped away to visit a friend who
lived nearby, thinking I'd be back before she
even noticed.
But of course it didn't go as planned.
Grandmother woke up while I was gone and
started asking questions.
She thought I was still sitting there quietly
next to her.
Poor Fekla didn't know what to do.
She couldn't understand what grandmother was saying and
panicked.
In her confusion, she undid the pin and
ran off.
At this point, Nastenka burst out laughing, the
memory clearly amusing her.
Her laughter was infectious and I couldn't help
but laugh with her, but she stopped almost
immediately and gave me a warning look.
I'm serious.
Don't you dare laugh at grandmother.
I'm only laughing because it was funny and—well,
what can I do?
That's just how grandmother is.
But I'm fond of her in my own
way.
Oh, how I caught it that time, though.
As soon as I came back, she pinned
me right back in place, and after that
there was no sneaking off again.
I wasn't allowed to stir an inch.
Oh, I almost forgot to tell you.
Our house belongs to us, or, rather, it
belongs to grandmother.
It's a small wooden house with three windows,
as old as grandmother herself.
There's also a tiny upper story.
Recently a new lodger moved into the upstairs
rooms.
Then you must have had an old lodger
before, I commented casually.
Of course we did, Nastenka replied with a
hint of exasperation, and let me tell you,
he knew how to keep quiet better than
you do.
In fact, he hardly spoke at all.
He was a frail, dried-up little old
man, deaf, blind, and lame.
He was so feeble that eventually he just
couldn't go on living anymore.
He passed away, and after that we had
to find someone new to rent the room.
We can't manage without a lodger.
The rent, along with grandmother's pension, is nearly
all we have to live on.
But this time the new lodger wasn't an
old man.
He was young, a stranger, not from around
here.
Grandmother took him in because he didn't haggle
over the rent.
It was only after he moved in that
she asked me, Nastenka, tell me, what's this
lodger of ours like?
Is he young or old?
I didn't want to lie to her, so
I told her the truth.
Well, grandmother, I said, he isn't exactly young,
but he's not old either.
And is he pleasant-looking, she asked?
I didn't see any point in lying about
that either.
Yes, grandmother, I said, he's pleasant-looking.
Oh, what a nuisance, grandmother exclaimed.
What a nuisance!
I tell you, Nastenka, you'd better not get
any ideas about him.
Times are so different now.
Why even a lodger like this?
And he has to be pleasant-looking, too.
It wasn't like this in the old days.
Grandmother was always reminiscing about the old days,
how everything was better back then.
In the old days, she would say, she
was young and full of energy, the sun
was warmer, the flowers bloomed more brightly, and
even the cream didn't turn sour so quickly.
Everything, it seemed, was perfect in the old
days.
Whenever she started talking like this, I would
sit quietly, holding my tongue, listening patiently while
she lamented the present and glorified the past.
But in my mind I couldn't help but
wonder why she had even brought up the
lodger's looks in the first place.
Why did she suggest it to me?
Why did she ask whether he was young
and good-looking?
But that was all I did.
I wondered for a moment, then I put
the thought out of my mind.
I counted the stitches on my knitting, focused
on my work, and forgot about the lodger
entirely.
Life carried on as usual.
One morning, however, the lodger came into our
room.
He had come to ask Grandmother about her
promise to have his rooms repapered.
The conversation started about wallpaper, but soon drifted
to other topics.
Grandmother, being naturally talkative, kept the conversation going.
At one point she said, "Nastenka, go into
my bedroom and bring me my reckoner." I
jumped up immediately, eager to fetch it for
her, but in my hurry I completely forgot
that my dress was still pinned to hers.
I blushed furiously, not knowing why, and instead
of quietly undoing the pin so that the
lodger wouldn't notice, I leapt up so quickly
that Grandmother's chair shifted.
The lodger's eyes widened slightly, and in that
instant he realized the full extent of my
predicament.
When it dawned on me that he now
knew everything, that he understood the ridiculous situation
I was in, I froze.
I stood as still as a statue, unable
to move, my face burning with embarrassment.
And then, to my utter horror, I felt
tears welling up in my eyes.
I didn't know where to look, didn't know
what to do.
Grandmother, unaware of what was happening, called out
again, "What are you waiting for?" But
her words only made things worse.
The tears began falling freely, and I was
completely overcome with shame and misery.
I felt as though I would sink into
the floor if I could.
The lodger, seeing how distraught I was, must
have felt sorry for me.
Without a word he gave a polite bow
and left the room quietly.
His kindness only deepened my embarrassment.
After that, I became terrified of hearing the
slightest sound in the hallway.
Every creak or shuffle of footsteps made my
heart race, and I would immediately think, "It's
him, the lodger!" I would frantically undo
the pin, just in case I needed to
escape quickly, but it never was him.
Day after day passed, and he didn't come
back.
A whole fortnight went by without any sign
of him.
Then one day he sent a message through
Fekla.
He told her he had a large collection
of French books, good, worthwhile books, and that
I might like to borrow them so I
wouldn't get bored.
He added that Grandmother might approve of this,
and he hoped it would help pass the
time.
When Fekla delivered the message, Grandmother, as always,
was cautious.
She accepted his kind offer with gratitude, but
immediately began asking questions.
"Are the books moral?" she asked.
"Because if they're not moral, then it's out
of the question.
You mustn't read anything improper, Nastenka.
People learn terrible things from such books." "What
terrible things, Grandmother?" I asked.
"What could possibly be in them?" "Oh,
plenty," Grandmother said gravely.
"These books are full of stories about how
young men seduce innocent, virtuous girls.
They pretend to love them, promise to marry
them, and then whisk them away from their
parents' homes, but once they've ruined the poor
girls' reputations, they abandon them, leaving them to
suffer the most pitiful fates." "I've read many
books like that myself," she added, almost
as an afterthought, "and I must say, they're
written so vividly that you can't help but
stay up all night reading them.
Of course, I read them on the sly
," she admitted with a sly little smile.
"But you, Nastenka, mustn't read such things.
What books has he sent you, anyway?"
"They're all Walter Scott novels, Grandmother," I
replied.
"Walter Scott's novels?" she repeated thoughtfully.
"Well, those sound proper enough.
But wait, are you sure he hasn't hidden
anything inside them?
These young men can be crafty.
Have you checked to see if there's a
love letter tucked inside the pages?" "No,
Grandmother, there's no love letter," I assured
her.
"Hmm," she said, unconvinced, "have you looked
under the binding?
Sometimes they slip things under the binding, those
rascals." "No, Grandmother," I said again, "there's
nothing under the binding." "Well, then," she
finally conceded, "if you're sure, that's all right."
So we began reading Walter Scott, and within
a month or so we had made our
way through almost half of the novels he'd
sent us.
Then more books began to arrive.
He sent us Pushkin as well, and soon
enough I couldn't imagine my days without a
book.
I left behind my childish daydreams of marrying
a Chinese prince, for now the stories I
read filled my mind with far richer and
more vivid fantasies.
That's how things were when one day, quite
by chance, I encountered our lodger on the
stairs.
Grandmother had sent me to fetch something, and
I was hurrying down when I saw him
coming up.
As we passed, he stopped, and for a
moment neither of us spoke.
I blushed, he blushed.
Then he broke the silence with a friendly
laugh, greeted me with a cheerful, "Good morning
," and asked how Grandmother was doing.
"Well," he added, "have you been reading
the books I sent?" I nodded and
said that I had.
"Which ones did you like best?" he
asked.
"Ivanhoe," I answered, "and Pushkin, most of
all." That was the extent of our conversation
that time.
I hurried away, feeling both shy and strangely
pleased, while he continued on his way upstairs.
A week later I ran into him again,
this time in much the same place.
Only this time Grandmother hadn't sent me on
an errand.
I had gone downstairs of my own accord
to fetch something.
It was just past two, and I knew
from habit that this was the hour he
usually returned home.
"Good afternoon," he said, as he stopped
on the stairs.
"Good afternoon," I replied, trying to keep
my voice steady.
"Aren't you bored?" he asked, "sitting with
your Grandmother all day long?" When he
said this, I felt an immediate rush of
embarrassment.
I didn't know why.
Perhaps it was because I felt as though
he had touched on a sensitive subject, one
that others had already whispered about.
It wasn't the first time someone had hinted
that my life was dull or limited, and
though I didn't like hearing it, I couldn't
deny there was truth in the question.
I felt both ashamed and offended, but I
also found myself rooted to the spot, unable
to walk away.
"Listen," he said gently, "you're a good
girl.
Forgive me for speaking so directly, but I
truly want what's best for you, just as
much as your Grandmother does.
Don't you have any friends you could visit,
someone to talk to or spend time with
?" I told him the truth.
"I don't have any friends now," I
said.
"I used to have one, Mashenka, but she
moved away to Pskov." "I see," he
said thoughtfully.
Then, after a pause, he added, "Would you
like to go to the theatre with me
sometime?" "The theatre?" I repeated, startled.
"But what about Grandmother?" "You'd have to
go without telling her," he said with
a quiet smile.
"No," I said firmly, "I don't want
to deceive Grandmother.
Good-bye." "Good-bye," he replied, and
though he said nothing more, there was something
in his voice that lingered with me, even
after he was gone.
Later that day, after dinner, he came to
see us in our little sitting room.
He stayed for quite a while talking to
Grandmother about this and that, asking her questions
about her life and habits.
At one point he casually asked if she
ever went out, if she had acquaintances or
places she liked to visit.
Grandmother shook her head, laughing, and said she
was too old for such things now.
Then, quite suddenly, he said, "I've taken a
box at the opera for tonight.
They're performing The Barber of Seville.
My friends were supposed to join me, but
they've cancelled, and now the ticket is going
to waste." "The Barber of Seville!" Grandmother
exclaimed, her face lighting up with interest.
"Why, that's the very same one they performed
in the old days." "Yes," he said
with a smile, glancing briefly at me.
"It's the same barber." I could feel my
face burning.
I knew what he meant by that glance,
and my heart began pounding in suspense.
I kept my eyes on the floor, not
daring to look up.
But I could feel Grandmother's excitement growing.
"To think of it," she said, "I
once played Rosina myself in a private performance.
That was many, many years ago." "Then perhaps
you'd like to go to-night," the
lodger suggested.
"It would be a shame for the ticket
to go unused." "By all means, let's go
," Grandmother declared with enthusiasm.
"Why shouldn't we?
And besides, my Nastenka here has never been
to the theatre in her life." My goodness,
what joy!
As soon as the plan was decided, we
began getting ready, without delay.
Grandmother and I put on our very best
clothes.
Even though she couldn't see, she was eager
to hear the music, and I could tell
she was just as excited as I was,
though for a different reason.
She was a kind and selfless soul, my
Grandmother, and what mattered most to her was
that I had the chance to enjoy myself.
She would never have gone to the theatre
on her own, but knowing it would bring
me happiness she agreed without hesitation.
As for me, I could hardly contain my
excitement.
The anticipation alone was thrilling.
When we finally arrived at the theatre and
took our seats, I could scarcely focus on
anything around me.
The lights, the crowd, the atmosphere, it was
all so overwhelming and magical.
What my impressions of the Barbara of Seville
were, I won't even attempt to describe.
The music, the performance, the characters, it felt
like I had stepped into an entirely new
world.
But what stood out even more to me
that evening was the way our lodger behaved.
He looked at me so kindly, spoke so
warmly, that it was impossible to mistake his
intentions.
I realized then that his suggestion that morning,
that I should go to the theatre with
him alone, had been a test, a way
of gauging my character, and knowing that made
me feel proud, like I had passed some
unspoken challenge.
That night, as I lay in bed, I
was brimming with happiness.
My heart was beating so fast that I
thought I might have a fever.
I couldn't stop thinking about the performance, replaying
every moment of it in my mind.
All night long I dreamed of the Barbara
of Seville, and when I woke the next
morning it felt as though I were still
under its spell.
Naturally, I expected that after such a delightful
evening, the lodger would start visiting us more
often.
But to my disappointment, that wasn't what happened
at all.
He seemed to grow even more distant.
He only came by about once a month,
and even then it was only to invite
us to the theatre again.
We went twice more, but by then my
joy had started to wane.
I began to feel that he didn't truly
care for me, that his kindness was only
out of pity for my situation.
He saw how strictly Grandmother treated me, and
that was the extent of his feelings, sympathy,
nothing more.
As time passed, I grew restless.
I couldn't focus on anything, not my reading,
not my knitting, not even my conversations with
Grandmother.
Some days I found myself laughing uncontrollably, doing
silly things just to provoke a reaction from
her.
Other days I would break down in tears
for no apparent reason.
My emotions were all over the place, and
I couldn't make sense of them.
I began to lose weight and felt constantly
on edge, as though something inside me was
about to break.
When the opera season ended, the lodger stopped
coming to see us entirely.
The only times I saw him were by
chance, on the stairs.
Each time he would bow silently, gravely, as
if trying to avoid any unnecessary interaction.
He would continue on his way, and I
would stand there, rooted to the spot, my
face burning red with embarrassment, my heart pounding
as though it might burst.
Then came the end.
It was exactly a year ago, in May,
when the lodger came to us with the
news.
He told Grandmother that his business in Petersburg
was finished, and that he would be returning
to Moscow for a year.
As soon as I heard those words, I
felt the ground shift beneath me.
My legs gave out, and I sank into
a chair, barely able to breathe.
Grandmother of course noticed nothing.
She simply listened politely as he explained his
plans, and when he finished, he bowed and
left the room.
I was devastated.
What was I to do?
I thought and thought, turning everything over in
my mind, but nothing made sense.
I felt trapped, helpless, as though my world
were collapsing around me.
Finally, I made up my mind.
The next day, he was to leave, and
I resolved to take action that very evening,
after Grandmother had gone to bed.
So it happened.
I gathered all my clothes, packed the linen
I would need, and tied everything into a
bundle.
With the parcel in hand, I climbed the
stairs to his room, more dead than alive.
My heart was pounding so violently that I
thought I might faint.
I stood outside his door for what felt
like an eternity, unable to summon the courage
to knock.
When I finally opened the door and stepped
inside, he turned to look at me.
His face went pale, and he cried out
in shock.
He thought I was a ghost.
Rushing to my side, he fetched a glass
of water, for I could barely stand.
My head was spinning, and I felt as
though I were about to collapse.
When I finally recovered enough to speak, I
placed my parcel on his bed, sat down
beside it, and buried my face in my
hands.
Tears poured from my eyes in a torrent,
and I couldn't stop myself.
I cried as though my heart were breaking,
and in a way it was.
I think he understood everything in that moment.
He didn't need me to explain.
He looked at me with such sadness, such
quiet regret, that it tore at my heart
even more.
Listen, he said gently.
Listen, Nastenka.
I can't do anything.
I am a poor man.
I have nothing, not even a proper job.
How could we live if I were to
marry you?
We talked for a long time.
I poured my heart out, telling him that
I couldn't bear living with Grandmother any longer,
that I felt like I was suffocating, that
I would rather run away than go on
like this.
I even said that I would follow him
to Moscow if only he would let me.
Shame, pride, and love were all swirling within
me, clashing and fighting for control.
At last, I collapsed onto the bed, overcome
with emotion, trembling with fear at the thought
of his refusal.
He sat in silence for several minutes.
Then, at last, he stood, walked over to
me, and took my hand.
Listen, my dear, good Nastenka.
Listen to me, he said, his voice soft
yet filled with urgency.
I swear to you that if I am
ever in a position to marry, you will
be the one to make me happy.
I assure you truly that right now you
are the only person who could bring joy
into my life.
But listen, Nastenka, I must go to Moscow.
I'll be there for a year, and during
that time I hope to improve my circumstances,
to establish myself properly.
When I return, if you still love me,
I swear to you that we will be
happy.
I will make sure of it, but right
now it's impossible.
I simply can't do it.
I don't have the means, nor do I
have the right to make any promises I
might not be able to keep.
Still, I repeat, if it doesn't happen within
a year, it will certainly happen at some
point.
That is, of course, only if you don't
prefer someone else during that time.
I could never ask you to bind yourself
to me with any sort of promise, and
I wouldn't dare try.
I want you to be free to choose.
That was what he said to me, and
the very next day he left for Moscow.
We agreed between us not to say a
word to grandmother.
That was his idea, his wish, and so
the matter was left as it was.
Well, she continued, her voice softening with a
mixture of sadness and resignation, that's almost the
end of my story.
A whole year has passed now.
He has come back.
He's been in Petersburg for three days already,
and—and—and what?
I interrupted eagerly, unable to contain my impatience.
What happened?
Has he come to see you?
And up to now he hasn't shown himself,
she answered, summoning all her courage to get
the words out.
Her voice trembled, and it seemed as though
even saying it aloud caused her pain.
There's been no sign, no word from him.
She stopped there, as though the weight of
her emotions had become too much to bear.
For a moment she sat still, her head
bowed.
Then, suddenly, she buried her face in her
hands and broke into such uncontrollable sobs that
it sent a pang straight through my heart.
I hadn't expected this.
I had thought her story would end differently,
more happily.
The sight of her despair was almost too
much for me to bear.
Nastenka, I began timidly, trying to keep my
voice gentle and soothing.
Nastenka, please don't cry.
How can you be so sure?
Maybe he hasn't arrived yet.
Perhaps there's been a delay.
No, no, he's here.
He's already here, she interrupted, her voice choked
with tears.
I know he is.
We made an agreement that evening before he
left.
We agreed on everything.
We came here, to this very embankment, after
we talked that night.
It was ten o'clock, and we sat
on this bench.
I wasn't crying then.
I felt so hopeful, so happy to hear
everything he said, and he told me that
as soon as he arrived back in Petersburg,
he would come to see me.
He said that if I didn't refuse him,
then we would tell grandmother everything.
But now he's here, and he hasn't come,
he hasn't come, and I don't understand why.
She broke into tears again, her shoulders shaking
as she tried to stifle her sobs.
Good God, Nastenka!
There must be something I can do to
help, I exclaimed, jumping up from the bench
in sheer desperation.
Tell me, tell me, Nastenka, wouldn't it be
possible for me to go to him, to
speak to him on your behalf?
Could you really do that, she asked suddenly,
raising her head and looking at me with
a glimmer of hope in her tear-filled
eyes.
No, no, I said, quickly pulling myself back
to reality.
Of course not, it's impossible.
But I'll tell you what, you could write
him a letter.
A letter, she repeated, shaking her head as
her hope faded.
No, that's impossible, I can't do that.
But why not, I insisted, clinging to my
idea.
Why can't you write him a letter?
It depends on the letter, Nastenka.
There are ways to write such letters.
Trust me, please, trust me, I wouldn't give
you bad advice.
It can be done.
You've already taken the first step once.
Why not now?
I can't, she said firmly, lowering her head
again.
I just can't.
It would feel as though I were forcing
myself on him.
Ah, my dear, sweet Nastenka, I said, barely
able to hide a small smile.
No, no, you have every right to reach
out to him.
Think about it.
He made you a promise.
He told you that if he married anyone
it would be you.
He even gave you the freedom to refuse
him, didn't he?
That shows he's a man of delicate feeling,
someone who cares about doing what's right.
Under the circumstances, you have every right to
take the first step.
In fact, you're in a privileged position.
You can even free him from his promise
if you feel it's necessary.
I paused, letting my words sink in.
Don't you see, Nastenka?
You have nothing to lose and everything to
gain.
Listen, how would you write it?
she asked suddenly, her voice trembling slightly with
a mix of uncertainty and determination.
Write what?
I asked, though I already had an idea
of what she meant.
This letter, she clarified, looking at me with
wide expectant eyes.
I hesitated for a moment, then nodded.
I'll tell you how I'd write it.
Begin with, Dear Sir.
Must I really start it like that?
she interrupted, frowning slightly.
Dear Sir?
Is that how it should begin?
Yes, you certainly must, I replied with confidence,
though almost immediately I wavered.
Though after all, I'm not entirely sure.
Perhaps it depends.
Maybe you could start differently if you feel
it suits you better.
Well, well, go on, she urged, leaning forward
eagerly.
What comes next?
Dear Sir, I began again, trying to compose
the rest of the letter in my mind.
I must apologize for—no, wait, that doesn't seem
right.
There's no need to apologize.
The very fact that you're writing justifies itself.
Apologies would only weaken the point.
Write simply, plainly, like this.
I am writing to you, forgive me my
impatience, but I have lived a whole year
in hope, and that hope has sustained me.
Am I to blame if I cannot bear
even a single day of doubt now that
you are here?
If by any chance your feelings have changed,
this letter is not to reproach you or
to plead.
It is only to tell you that I
do not hold you responsible, nor do I
blame you.
How could I, when I have no power
over your heart?
Such is my fate.
I know you to be an honorable man.
You will not ridicule or grow angry over
these lines, written in such haste and emotion.
Please remember that they come from a poor
girl who is entirely alone, who has no
one to guide her or advise her, and
who has always struggled to control her heart.
If a shadow of doubt has crept into
my heart, forgive me for it.
I know you are not capable of offending,
even in thought, someone who has loved you
so deeply and continues to love you still.
I stopped and glanced at her.
Nastenka's face had lit up with joy, her
eyes sparkling with excitement.
She clapped her hands together and exclaimed, Yes,
yes, that's exactly what I was thinking.
Oh, you've solved everything for me.
God has truly sent you to me.
Thank you, thank you.
I couldn't help but smile at her enthusiasm.
Thank me?
What for?
For God sending me your way?
I asked, half teasing, but entirely delighted by
the happiness in her expression.
Yes, for that too, she replied with a
playful laugh, her cheeks glowing with warmth.
Ah, Nastenka, I said, my voice softening.
There are moments in life when one feels
grateful simply for existing at the same time
as someone else.
I thank you, not just for meeting me,
but for giving me something I'll remember for
the rest of my life.
She smiled at that, but quickly waved her
hand as though brushing away my words.
Enough, enough of that.
Listen now.
Let me tell you what we agreed upon
that night before he left.
We decided that as soon as he returned,
he would let me know by leaving a
letter with some good, trustworthy people I know,
people who know nothing of the situation.
Or if writing a letter was impossible, since
letters can't always say everything, he promised to
meet me here, at this very spot, at
ten o'clock on the day he arrived.
I know he's already back, I feel it.
But now it's been three days and there's
still no sign of him, no letter, no
message, nothing.
And it's impossible for me to leave grandmother
alone in the mornings.
So please, here's what I need you to
do.
Take my letter to those kind people I
mentioned.
They'll send it on to him.
If he replies, bring his answer here tomorrow
at ten o'clock.
I hesitated for a moment, thinking through the
logistics of her request.
But the letter—I said—you have to write the
letter first.
That might delay things, so, perhaps, everything will
have to wait until the day after tomorrow.
The letter—Nastenka repeated, her voice faltering slightly as
a flicker of uncertainty crossed her face.
She looked down, fiddling nervously with her hands.
The letter— But— She trailed off, leaving her
thoughts unfinished.
But she didn't finish her sentence.
Instead, she quickly turned her face away from
me, her cheeks flushing the deepest pink, as
though a rose had bloomed upon her skin.
For a moment she hesitated, and then, without
a word, I felt something soft pressed into
my hand.
Looking down, I realized it was a letter—sealed,
prepared, and clearly written long before.
She must have carried it with her all
this time, ready for this moment, though perhaps
unsure whether she would have the courage to
hand it over.
As I stood there, a familiar, sweet memory
swept over me.
A thought that seemed as if it had
sprung to life from some tender corner of
my imagination surfaced unbidden.
I couldn't help myself.
With a mischievous grin I began softly, R
-O-R-O-S-I-C-N-A
-N-A.
Rosina!
we both burst out together, humming the name
in unison.
The laughter that followed seemed to fill the
quiet street, mingling with the soft evening air.
In my delight I came close to embracing
her, swept up in the shared joy of
that silly little moment.
it.
Her laughter mixed with mine, though her cheeks
grew even redder and tears glistened at the
corners of her eyes.
They sparkled like tiny pearls against the dark
curtain of her eyelashes, catching the faint light.
"'Enough, enough!
Stop it now!' she exclaimed, half laughing and
half scolding, though her own voice betrayed her
amusement.
"'Good-bye for now,' she added hastily, as
though trying to end the moment before her
emotions got the better of her again.
"'Here's the letter.
Take it.
And here's the address where you're to deliver
it.
Don't forget.
Good-bye, till we meet again.
Till tomorrow.' Her words tumbled out so quickly
that I hardly had time to respond.
Before I could say anything more, she pressed
both my hands in hers with a warmth
and sincerity that left me momentarily stunned.
Her grip was firm, but her hands trembled
slightly, as though she were both eager and
afraid of what would come next.
She gave me one last bright, fleeting smile,
nodded her head quickly as if to reassure
herself, and then turned and darted away.
She moved so quickly, so gracefully, that she
seemed almost to fly.
Like an arrow loosed from a bow, she
vanished down the side street, her footsteps light
and quick against the cobblestones.
I stood there, rooted to the spot, unable
to move, watching her retreating figure as it
disappeared into the shadows.
Even after she was gone, her voice lingered
in my ears.
"'Till tomorrow.
Till tomorrow.' The words echoed, their warmth wrapping
around me like a melody that refused to
fade.
I stood there for what felt like an
eternity, staring at the empty street where she
had just been, my heart full of something
indescribable.
And then, at last, I turned and began
to make my way home, her letter clutched
tightly in my hand.